[Music]
did you know in the beginning that it
would be a hit like this Oh feel it on
set oh I did I think we knew we had kind
of a good thing going in everything kind
of felt good
yeah shits Creek is a bonafide hit
thanks in part to Canadian comedic
legends Eugene Levy and Catherine O'Hara
stop persecuting your father we all know
he's in a bad way
no bad way my IRA I'm actually feeling
pretty good you had some great success
at the Canadian Screen Awards what does
that feel like going into season three
it was really an amazing year and the
you know the the CSA's the nominations
and wins were I don't know what is it
like a little pat on the back for her
hey I like your show what can we expect
for season three it's the family now
getting on with their lives and their
lives are now in shits Creek and they
never give up I fight this they never
they never give up we seem to have
caught the boys in an afternoon delight
does that term still a thing never say
that don't do that here you are shooting
season three more pressure in the
writing room when you're thinking about
where you're gonna take each character
and when we started out writing the
first season of the show there were no
expectations right and something about
it seems to connect and it's been really
great coming back into season three like
everyone just seems it all has gelled
and click the family is going into its
third you know season of living together
in this motel and I'm never gonna get a
house note like is I'm sorry charming